foreign
[Music]
Nintendo released new Super Mario
Brothers for the Nintendo DS which if
you don't count the Game Boy Advance
ports of NES and SNES titles was the
first new and original 2D platformer
since Super Mario Land 2. it's kind of
crazy to think that there was such a
large time Gap in the 2D Mario library
with more than 30 million units sold the
game was a Smash Hit and fans of the red
and blue plumber were happy to see the
series return to its side-scrolling
roots then they made another one and
another one and another one and another
one kinda in terms of quality they're
all solid entries but the almost
identical art style as well as the speed
at which they were turning them out did
render the new Super Mario Bros series a
bit unremarkable especially compared to
the older games most of which have a
distinguishable look and feel enter the
Super Mario Maker series Nintendo's way
of saying fine make your own damn game
you bunch of babies the concept of an
official stage Builder from Mario made
perfect sense and honestly it was a long
time coming people have been creating
ROM hacks and homebrews since the 80s
some amateuristic some very true to form
and others relentlessly and sadistically
difficult Mario Maker gives anyone the
opportunity to be creative and
essentially build their own homemade
Mario game without any experience in
coding visual design or video game
engines and since the future of 2D Mario
is a bit uncertain right now the game
ensures that those who crave more
side-scrolling Mario action will have a
near endless supply of levels and worlds
to play for years to come but there's
another famous Nintendo IP which has
been kinda on the down low in the 2D
Department the last 2D Zelda which
wasn't a port or a remake came out in
2015 and primarily focused on
multiplayer in that sense you could say
that A Link Between Worlds from 2013 was
the last true to form top down Zelda
game although nothing is out of the
realm of possibility at this stage when
it comes to 2D Zelda I feel like we'll
be seeing even more remakes as opposed
to brand new titles an unfortunate Trend
in the current age of video games in my
opinion it's no surprise then that many
people have been predicting or
advocating for a similar concept as seen
with Mario a Zelda maker if you will
however other games even the top-down
installments are a very different Beast
compared to a Mario side scroller the
games are all about exploring a vast
World NPC interaction puzzles finding
hidden secrets and witnessing a story
unfold definitely a step up from running
and jumping from point A to point B as
many have pointed out one option would
be to narrow it down to only one aspect
of the series more specifically dungeons
which the series is famous for this
would indeed make it a lot more
manageable they are self-contained
challenges that can function without a
grander story but it also means that as
opposed to Mario Maker which can present
something very close to a genuine 2D
Mario experience a Zelda dungeon Builder
cannot after all dungeons are but one of
many elements that make a Zelda game a
Zelda game is still that doesn't mean
that a dungeon maker is a bad idea it
may not be able to substitute a real
Zelda experience but for a lot of people
dungeons are one of the most enjoyable
elements in the franchise to some extent
Nintendo already experimented with the
concept in the 2019 remake of Link's
Awakening though for reasons I'll get
into shortly it was a far cry from what
people in mind and Mark into a mini game
than an actual gameplay mode so how
would one go about creating something
like a dungeon maker what are the
limitations and roadblocks for a project
like this after looking into it for the
past weeks I can confidently say that
it's definitely not as straightforward
as Mario Maker because Zelda dungeons
deal with all kinds of mechanics that
can easily become problematic first and
foremost is finding a balance between
accessibility and versatility there's
plenty of examples of level editors map
makers and game design tools that are
either integrated into the game itself
or function as a mod or a standalone
title some are very basic and beginner
friendly While others are so complex
that they border on an actual gaming
engine which is definitely not for
everyone a big part of Mario Maker's
success is how intuitive it is the UI
manages to communicate most of the
available options purely through visuals
in the base tutorial in just a couple of
hours of fiddling around are enough to
get started there's no need for node
setups complicated game logic and
configurations or walls of text and
documentation simply by dragging and
dropping objects on top of each other
letting them enter act and messing
around with the different options and
you'll quickly get a grasp on what's
possible and once everything clicks the
only thing holding you back is your own
creativity I mean people have made fully
functional calculators with this thing
for a dungeon maker I think a similar
approach is absolutely necessary it
needs to be easy to understand yet
present enough options and versatility
to create some amazing stuff the last
thing you want is having to look up a
tutorial every two minutes but you also
don't want to play so many restrictions
that dungeons end up feeling way too
similar Link's awakening's dungeon
Creator definitely suffered from the
latter you cannot even create your own
custom Chambers instead you can only
choose from pre-existing ones and
arrange them into a grid these rooms are
also not unique to the Creator itself
and are simply recycled from The Game's
story dungeons furthermore all the
content inside the room are baked in the
amount of doorways whether it has locked
doors contains a chest the enemies and
so on as such it's impossible to create
your own puzzle scenarios Beyond how you
navigate the dungeon as a whole and even
this is severely limited as the game
logic often decides things for you you
depending on how the rooms are laid out
for example if you place a room with a
locked door and two accessible rooms to
the side of it each containing a chest
the key to the door will be in the first
chest you check or maybe it's randomized
I'm still not sure but the point is you
have no control over what's inside of a
chest same goes with staircases which
always seem to connect to each other
randomly I don't want to sound too harsh
or demanding because the dungeon Creator
in Link's Awakening is so obviously
meant to be an extra like I said before
it's more of a mini game and I actually
did have fun with it for a couple of
hours but if Nintendo ever decides to go
all the way and create a standalone
Zelda maker it's safe to say that it has
to be a lot meatier than this Nintendo
Lance wants something a bit Messier so
let's start with the basics creating an
overall dungeon layout and individual
rooms I don't think I have to explain
why 3D Zelda dungeons are out of the
question structures like these and their
Central mechanics are way too complex to
recreate in the type of level design
tool we're talking about they would
either have to be heavily simplified and
cut down in regards to what you can or
cannot do which goes against the whole
principle of a 3D Zelda dungeon or the
design tool itself would have to be at
the same level as something like Halo
forge which means losing accessibility
the 2D or top down format is a lot more
manageable in that regard the space is
clear and easy to understand there's
less directions and physics to deal with
and more importantly just like Mario
it's all grid based which I think is
essential to keep it comprehensible the
only consideration that remains is
whether you want to go for a true 2D
experience I.E Sprite bass Like A Link
to the Past or Minish Cap or a top-down
3D engine like Link's Awakening or Link
Between Worlds both options should work
fine as long as the level editor remains
top-down oriented and they could even go
with a combination between the two it's
not too difficult to create a 3D
environment that looks like a classic
Zelda dungeon from a bird's eye
perspective if you apply pixel based
textures as you can see here one major
benefit to this approach is that it
presents the option to switch between
many different art styles on the fly
from classic 8-bit to 16-bit to a more
realistic one as seen in links away
Awakening a similar option is already
present in Mario Maker which includes
three classic themes plus the new Super
Mario Bros art style which utilizes 3D
models whatever they choose to go with
the same basic rules apply regardless
and Nintendo already has the tools to do
both the Link's Awakening engine and as
you may remember they created a 2d demo
to test out some of breath of the Wild's
mechanics I do think that in the case of
Zelda there needs to be a lot more
texture and coloring options than we see
in Mario if not dungeons will quickly
end up looking the same or become
repetitive this can easily be fixed with
a wide variety of walls and Floors to
choose from ornaments and decorations
like Vines cobwebs debris and so on as
well as the option to change the Hue of
specific texture groups this way people
can express their creativity and make
their dungeons more unique I thought
about the option for custom texturing as
well but first of all the switch's
touchscreen is not exactly on the same
level as a drawing tablet and drawing
with an analog stick no thank you
secondly I'm not so sure if Nintendo
would put their faith in the maturity of
their demographic if you get my drift
when it comes to the editor there's
really only two types necessary to
construct a dungeon a level editor where
you'll be constructing individual rooms
and of course a map editor this is
obviously the starting point and it's
from here that you'll be creating
Chambers and arranging them into a
larger structure similar to Link's
Awakening but there's a couple of things
I would add to it first is multiple
floors which has become a staple of
Zelda dungeons it gives the structure
depth and verticality despite not being
full 3d not to mention you can only fit
so many rooms side by side in a grid
like this so additional floors will
allow you to build something a lot
bigger it also allows for more variation
in how you connect certain parts of the
dungeon as opposed to just walking from
room to room you can also Place chasms
elevators or stairways that take you to
a floor below second is the option to
create rooms of various sizes Link's
Awakening only lets you choose from
single screen dungeon rooms locations
that have a scrolling camera like the
central chamber of eagles tower for
example have all been excluded which is
quite limiting being able to create
spaces that span multiple grid blocks
would be a big Improvement in that
regard I do realize that there has to be
a limit to it if only for the sake of
the engine so let's say a maximum of
three or four blocks total I think this
would be enough to spice it up a bit
finally I would include the option to
save rooms as templates either from
within the map editor or inside the
level editor or both this way you can
create your own library of rooms which
can be transferred between different
dungeon projects and reused of course
not every room you create will be
something special so this should
definitely be optional as for the level
editor I think Mario Maker already laid
a solid groundwork placing objects in
terrain by drawing drag and drop copy
and erase group select the usual stuff I
was able to code a very basic room
editor in just a few days and I'm a
horrible programmer so it shouldn't be
much of a problem for the Wizards at
Nintendo granted mine is by no means an
accurate representation and cannot even
be played but you know it's a
demonstration nothing more I did run
into a bit of a conundrum whilst working
on it though I really like the idea of
being able to give the room a custom
shape and placing exits anywhere you
please it would definitely make the
dungeon more varied when you're not
restricted two rectangular rooms only
but it can pose a bit of a problem when
you're trying to connect them into the
larger structure you would have to keep
close track of exactly where you placed
your exits and make sure they're not
misaligned I don't really have a
definitive solution for it maybe the
placement of exits has to be restricted
to specific spots only like in the
middle and corners of the outer walls
for example or they could restrict
shaping the outer walls altogether and
instead let you choose from a
predetermined set of room shapes it is
more user-friendly this way but it does
take away from creative freedom and I
don't know if this is a good trade-off
maybe people don't mind correcting these
types of misalignments be sure to let me
know what you think so that covers the
basics for shaping the overall dungeon
structure there's definitely some
hurdles and roadblocks to consider and
overcome but I think overall it's more
than manageable but now we get to the
difficult stuff since what good is a
Zelda dungeon without enemies hazards
and of course puzzles now I think
enemies and Hazards don't pose much of a
problem either some pits here lava there
spike traps moving platforms all the
good stuff as for the enemies I'm sure
enough tendo has all the essential AI
for all the different types stored
somewhere as long as there's a decent
selection to choose from and they can
adapt to the layout of the room it
should work just fine the same goes for
bosses and mini bosses though for the
final boss they may want to consider the
same type of approach as Link's
Awakening and pair them up with a
pre-built boss room after all some of
them do require a certain setup to
accommodate their moveset like lava for
example but the real challenge lies in
creating puzzles which are an essential
part of a Zelda dungeon it's safe to say
that pre-made puzzle setups as seen in
Link's Awakening are definitely a no-go
since there's only so many scenarios
they can include sooner or later players
will have encountered every setup in the
game and thus they'll know how to solve
each and every one what you want to do
is give people the opportunity to come
up with their own puzzle scenarios from
scratch to start off you'll need a wide
selection of objects to work with like
different types of switches weapons
conveyor belts locks and keys moving
platforms just to name a few and enemies
can be utilized for this purpose as well
the next step is that these objects need
to be able to interact and talk to one
another in some way for certain objects
particularly physics-based ones this can
simply be pre-programmed by the
Developers for example moving a block
onto a floor switch will cause it to
activate or placing a movable object
onto a conveyor belt or a moving
platform will influence its momentum
this is nothing special and we've
already seen this kind of stuff in Mario
Maker these are rules set up by the
developers and don't require input from
the player but what about objects that
can trigger events through other memes
as an example if I create a room with a
closed door and a floor switch how will
the engine know that pressing this
switch should open up the door of course
you could pre-program door objects to
automatically detect if there's a switch
present in the room and react to it when
pressed but what if I don't want that
what if I want this floor switch to
spawn a chest instead and shooting this
eye switch will activate the door under
normal circumstances like in an actual
game engine you would need something
like nodes or straight up coding to give
instructions on what should happen to
Which object but preferably we want to
stay away from that kind of stuff so
let's take a look at an example from
another game namely time Splitters 2
which if you didn't play this game game
back in the day you were definitely
missing out because it was one of the
best console Shooters of its time in my
opinion made by some of the same people
who worked on Goldeneye 64. the amount
of content it provides is absolutely
stunning an amazing campaign awesome
music classic arcade lots and lots of
multiplayer modes and as a cherry on top
they included a fully fleshed out map
maker which for its time was so much
better than it had any right to be in
fact you can bet that in this day and
age a mode like this would be sold as 20
DLC or something they really don't make
games like these anymore you know what's
impressive about time Splitters map
maker is not the level creation itself
while it does have rooms of various
sizes they're all pre-made and the
choice is pretty limited it has the
option for multiple floors but there's
only a few different themes which don't
offer a whole lot of variety and the
choice of actors and objects is also
nothing to write home about but where
Chimes is in the option to insert your
own game logic into your level by
setting up triggers and actions you can
create your own events custom objectives
Mission structure briefings enemy
behavior and Patrol routes all without a
single line of code triggers can involve
anything from activating a switch
destroying an object reaching a certain
location on the map killing a certain
enemy having an enemy spot you and so on
these triggers can then be linked to a
specific action like making a key appear
spawning an enemy or weapon blowing up a
computer terminal and much much more by
linking all these different objects
together you can create all sorts of
scenarios mission objectives and chain
reactions for example I can destroy this
box which then kills this enemy which in
turn makes a key card appear so I can
open up this door it's pretty neat
there's essentially no limit to how many
actions can be linked to one single
trigger which allows for so many
different types of setups the only thing
I don't like about the logic section is
the UI it's all text based which makes
it hard to keep track of all the objects
and events you've set up and how they
relate to one another it's completely
disconnected from the map itself and it
took me a while to understand how the
system actually works the objects you've
applied logic to are visible on the map
screen and you can rotate and move them
around and such but you can see what
they do or what they are connected to
for a Zelda dungeon Builder you want to
have a similar system where you can link
objects to each other to trigger certain
actions but just like Mario Maker it's
preferable to do it visually right
inside the editor and not in a separate
disconnected screen filled with text the
types of objects you link together will
determine the action that follows
linking a door to a switch speaks for
itself the door will open once the
switch is pressed but linking a chest to
one or more enemies for example may turn
it invisible and will spawn as soon as
said enemies are defeated additionally
if something is linked to more than one
object say you connect a door to four
switches you could add even more options
like whether or not you have to press
all four or if any will do or you can
set up an order in which they need to be
pressed and then hide the Secret order
in the dungeon somewhere perhaps in the
level design with a system like this you
could practically recreate 90 of the
typical 2D Zelda puzzles and more I'm
sure there's plenty of flaws and
limitations to it stuff I haven't even
thought about yet but it's the best
solution I can currently think of and if
they include enough gizmos and
combination to work with you can create
some pretty nifty puzzle scenarios of
course there's a lot more to think about
and consider when it comes to a Zelda
dungeon but I think we have the basics
covered consider this as a sort of pitch
to Nintendo I guess I'm not actually
planning to make a dungeon Builder
myself nor do I claim to be able to I'd
love to take on the challenge someday
but right now I've got other things to
do man the most important aspect is that
it remains as user-friendly as possible
while at the same time providing enough
options to create something unique and
exciting despite its overall Simplicity
people have created some truly amazing
stuff in Mario Maker by exploiting the
options available the last thing to
mention is that the system should be
able to catch and autocorrect as much as
possible what I mean by that is that the
game should be able to account for
oversights without immediately making
the dungeon itself unplayable every time
you want to test the dungeon you want to
avoid a long list of error messages
because certain things aren't properly
set up which is something that was kind
of annoying in Link's Awakening in
TimeSplitters 2 for example if a door or
hallway doesn't connect to anything it
simply turns into a wall automatically
if you place only one warp Point without
a destination it just sits there and
doesn't do anything the same should
apply to a dungeon maker disconnect the
doors turning into walls staircases that
don't lead anywhere should either do
nothing or be invisible when the level
compiles and if you place a traversable
Chasm but forget to put a room
underneath to land on it'll
automatically turn into a bottomless pit
at the same time you also don't want to
take away too much freedom I thought
about issues like having more locked
doors than there are Keys potentially
soft locking those who play your level
which I'm sure there's a solution for
but at the same time I think people
should also be left to their own devices
players will no doubt create dungeons
that are extremely unfair but just like
Mario maker that's what the voting
system is for if your dungeon sucks
others will surely let you know the only
restriction I do think is fair is that
just like in Mario Maker you have to be
able to beat your own level before being
allowed to upload it so even if it's
totally unfair you'll at least know that
there is a way to get to the end and
that is all I have to say about it maybe
one day we'll see something like this
being realized or maybe it's a lot more
difficult than I make it out to be I'm
not even close to working out every
aspect of it so I'm sure there's a
developer out there who's like yeah not
gonna happen that said there are some
amazing Indie projects in development
right now that showcase the potential of
stuff like Dynamic Landscaping like this
project by oh boy Anastasia opara who
was kind enough to let me use some of
their footage there's a link to their
social media accounts in the description
below so you can follow their progress
for yourself while this may not apply to
a top-down Zelda game very well in terms
of perspective it does illustrate how
terrain walls and Floors can
intelligently adjust and reshape
themselves to fit their surroundings
which just looks so cool in my opinion
and as a coding method it may be useful
for a future Zelda maker as well anyway
a massive thanks to everyone who
supports the channel to narrow for
letting me use some of his footage a big
fan of your content by the way to local
hourglass for joining my patreon and
Arya pie Rodrigo Lunas and hyrule's
Warrior for becoming a member thank you
all very much it means a lot I will see
you all next time this is Dawn signing
off and have a good one
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]